are we alive
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world
um we're missing Harris he's overslept
bless him but he'll be with us in a
minute
kids today eh what can you do you can't
trust them to just turn up on time but
Matt is with us say hello I am my alarm
clock went off
yeah but it also helps that it's like
five o'clock in the afternoon for us and
it's nine o'clock so I
we've been able to get up at nine
o'clock on a Sunday
you're a kid no not at all not at all no
but anyway this week it is I'm Gonna
Roll the credits
[Music]
it is Stargate Sunday live it is our
monthly look at Everton Stargate this
week we do have a couple of updates for
you to discuss one of the updates
um is looking at god of war and how that
might affect what's going on with
Stargate and penguin in a Parker
um I've got a little bit of an update on
that and we'll also I just want to have
a chat about sort of the management
structure at Amazon I know it's boring
but it does really affect this and
finally we're going to have a little bit
of a chat about hey Jordan Ada hey
Shelly Hines and hello howdy howdy
moving a little
you're like
I know was I that predictable you knew
exactly where I was in this hour
so
um before we get to oh Harris how are
you sir how you doing
pretty well how about y'all
very well thank you
good good
a million times better I can actually
move I ran I ran upstairs a minute hey
no way did you get that little like
Electro acupressure or whatever
no no it's just it's just got better
rolling stomachs I'm so rock hard
basically because I'm so manly it's just
it's just yeah I've got my new cup look
um
even my wife said isn't that nice yes
that's recognize that the new Sidetrack
logo just looks better and better every
time I see it you know yeah it's it's a
sexy logo so
um uh also today what we're going to do
is we're going to have a look at series
five of Stargate and we're gonna have a
chat about what we think the series that
brought us Anubis so most definitely
want to have a chat about that at any
point if you see me go
it's because man united are playing
Liverpool
um and because I love you guys so much
I'm not watching it
instead I'm here with you guys and it's
nil nil at the moment so
every so often you might just see me
going
and if I get angry if we if we lose I'm
just going to turn the stream off and go
and cry so
we are also going to have a look at very
quickly the top 10 list that I did a
video on a couple of days ago should we
start there
so it's just top 10 list
so at 1.3 million votes on this list of
the top 10 greatest Sci-Fi series of all
time right
now
I've got a couple of little problems
with this list
I'll run through it though and guys
please get in the comments tell me what
you think
um Judith Khan loves his new side track
shirt is it arrived already mate because
my this cup I mean I know I shouldn't
really say this because I want to sell
these things but it took like two months
to come
it took ages
um so I'm not prison demand isn't it
that's what that's what happens exactly
the t-shirt in my hat at the same time
um that came ages ago
the cookware anyway so but if you're in
America I think it's a lot quicker
um anyway so there's a little bit for
this shirt to come to be fair I think it
was about two weeks yeah normally it's
about two weeks I know the cup took so
long um but anyway
um it's awesome and I love it so cheers
um I need to send you guys cups so you
can drink while you're uh
we'll do a little virtual cheering every
day yeah yeah I I we don't do a cup big
enough for you Harris
but we'll bring the water machine into
here
hahaha
right this this side track um this list
though right so guys I'd love you guys
to jump on tell us what you think of
this list so number 10 Star Trek the
Original Series
it's the Daddy it's the it's not to
start the genre it would be weird if it
wasn't on the list even though a lot of
the episodes haven't dated very well it
would be weird if it wasn't honest
number nine The X-Files probably at the
time the most popular television show on
telly so okay
number eight the Orville I love the
Orville
but top 10 greatest Sci-Fi series of all
time
I'll put a question mark for that I
think I think it it deserves to be there
but not just yet it is it has potential
to be one of the greatest TV shows of
all time but it's not quite there yet
I'm going to ask you a question in a bit
so I'm going I'm doing I'm marking the
series that we're not so sure about okay
I don't know judican is wearing his
T-shirt now blessing
thank you very much sir hi Sarah hi Jess
just say hello to everybody hello Shelly
yeah they're a bit slow but I actually
think that the quality is really good so
even though they are a bit slow a bit
little bit expensive as well to be
honest but but they do it individually
though don't they sell you when you get
that if I could print a thousand enough
if I thought they would sell I could do
it loads cheaper but and they wouldn't
sell so anyway
um so yeah number thing um number uh
seven Battle Star Galactica now it
doesn't say whether it's a new one or
the old one but I'm assuming it's the
royalty more version
um I think that's fair enough it changes
even though it knows dive towards the
end
um the mini series in particular was
stunning
um strangest thing I wouldn't get stuck
at Universal value probably
well they copied it pretty much
you know the style not the story right
now the style
um number six stranger things
I'm not sure that's sci-fi
it's definitely sci-fi yeah what else is
it it's not fantasy it's close but
it's it's like a Sci-Fi
I know there's like it's it's a science
fiction thing and it's like there's a
device that creates a thing but it's
more is it Horror oh
in the same sense aliens Maybe
yeah I'm not sure but again this is the
only it's this in The X-Files are
probably the most like generally popular
series on this list that like
everybody watches it everybody watch
stranger things everybody watch The
X-Files back in the day
um number five the Next Generation
I'm Star Trek I'm okay with that because
that's my Star Trek to be honest
and so I'm I'm on board with that
um number four
SG-1
so I'm so happy that this made this list
and I'm so happy it's so high up
um so number four the uh number three
the Star Wars fans had to vote for
something
so they voted for Mandalorian and they
put it in at number three that's how I
saw it I was in the Mandalorian group
and someone in there posted it as well I
need to share this
immediately
[Music]
disgusting
um
yeah number three Mandalorian number two
the expanse
of deservedly so
I think that's high
well I'll discuss why in a second but is
it greater than Stargate I don't think
so
yeah it's a brilliant show and I got
loads of respect for it but it's got
limited popularity
the people that love the expanse love
the expanse and I'm one of those people
don't get me wrong
um but
number two the second best sci-fi show
ever
what is it might have something to do
with
um it might have something to do with
the fact that it's been on recently
yeah
on this list because it's on at the
moment yeah I I'd like to know just what
question everybody that was pulled was
asked so then we have parameters for
what best is is it most popular or is it
like what did this series
yeah that's kind of what I feel like
which is it's not the same as best but
your favorite
um but the expanse has no popular book
I can't say many series that I I have
more respect for
but anyway but number one
and I and this is a show I adore I love
it so much it's the show I've watched
over and over and over and over and over
and I was literally watching it Thursday
um is Firefly
but
it's it's only had 14 episodes is it 14
or 16. I always get that wrong I think
it's 14.
um
it was brilliant
but the greatest Sci-Fi show ever I'm
not sure about that
I mean you ask any sci-fi fan I was
about to say I still haven't even seen
the series and everybody yeah I'm the
same I've not seen it but everyone who
I've ever asked it was a Sci-Fi fan
they're just like you need to watch
Firefly it's the one one show everyone
always goes and it's on my list I'm
gonna watch it we're gonna come at me in
the comments I'm gonna watch it but only
take 14 hours it's not that long it's
the show that everyone tells you to
watch so I understand why it's number
one you've got to get past the first
couple of episodes so because even I who
adore it was there going
Cowboys in space
um but once you fall in love with the
characters
it's just it's just me the Jordan 8 has
just said it's 14 episodes I thought it
was because I think I got that wrong
last time
so um yeah 14 episodes Jordan um brain
pain is just don't don't think
um yeah Sarah's got that right now you
need to turn in your nerd cart your new
channel
um it's called nerd corn and that's
correct I believe please go away and
subscribe to Matt's new channel yeah um
you need to call it not nerd Channel
because I haven't watched Firefly yet
but as soon as I have watched Firefly
I'll change my name back to nerd Corner
the channel
it's mainly
a channel but everything that isn't
sci-fi
we do sci-fi here I'm not doing sci-fi
over there apart from Doctor Who
because Doctor Who can be it is sci-fi
but it can be like categorizing other
things as well
superheroes and things yeah
yeah you better not do any sci-fi on
there mate or I'm going to come around
and kick in the nuts oh I'm gonna do a
Stargate Universe video it's going to
bang or to make millions
laughs
that was a great interaction that was he
made it even better all right so see my
channel is just movies money and Mary
Jane we don't we don't go over all that
you know we'll we'll go over to that by
movie but yeah and leave all that over
here
just uh
the question I was going to say right
um sorry Babylon five
not on this list
somebody just asked for what no fire
escape fast games not on this list and
farscape's a great series I've got a
video coming up on Fastback very shortly
that's going to excite people that
enjoyed it
um earlier in the chat Jess put in Lost
in Space I'm surprised the old or the
new version's not on there either
honestly over like the Orville you know
something like that
Doctor Who
the longest ones yeah I was surprised
that wasn't on the list at all but it's
it's more of a pretty simple drama than
a Sci-Fi huh
yeah but still very much a Sci-Fi I mean
if you're if we were arguing that
stranger things is a Sci-Fi which has
sci-fi elements to it but really isn't
the driving force behind the show you've
got to say Doctor Who is a Sci-Fi but 11
is the driving force behind that show I
don't know a stranger things is a hard
sci-fi no 11 is definitely a Sci-Fi
character I mean she's got two yeah
she's Luke Skywalker hey I mean she's
burning right yeah
this is probably that I think there's a
couple of episodes in there that I think
Firefly is very much sci-fi science
fiction fans and they voted for it
because they miss it so much that's why
it's ingrained in us because we're like
14 episodes it was not enough God damn
you
um so I think that's there that's why
that's there I think stranger things is
in there because people that aren't
really aren't hardcore sci-fi fans I've
been voted for a show they know and I
think that's probably why the X-Files is
there as well
I don't think most hardcore sci-fi fans
would have stranger things in X-Files on
this list I don't think they'd consider
them proper sci-fi
X-Files just and then it had sci-fi but
it also had ghosts and monsters and all
sorts it was horror it was you know it
had a bit of everything in there
um it's almost more of a cathedral drama
as well
yeah yeah it's I I would throw out
stranger things and add Babylon five and
I would throw out X-Files and put Doctor
Who
myself
so Doctor Who and at number nine and um
Babylon five in at number six
but then I might wiggle some of the
other numbers around but the thing with
Doctor Who
it is really good and it is a staple in
sci-fi but it peaked in popularity
like 10 years ago and then it's just
gone downhill I mean it was popular
before but it was never as popular as it
was 10 years ago that was that was the
pie of Doctor Who when it was worldwide
when everyone watched it and it was like
a household name everyone's like
everyone loved it
someone's obviously just scored on the
other side
one nil God damn it we were trying to
bite him as well
um
just before half time I think I'm gonna
uh I'm wearing not just one but two man
united shirts and man united pants and
really man united up today
um by accident but yeah
um it's just I I think it's a strongly
odd list but I think it's almost
suffered by how many people have voted
for it almost because there's I think
there's a couple of like popular choices
on there rather than hardcore scientific
but hey it's it's fascinating to watch
and guys watch Firefly we'll do a video
on it in a couple of weeks you guys can
watch it in the next two to three weeks
all right and then we'll do a video on
it and your feelings from because
honestly you're gonna freaking love it
you will love it honestly it'll make you
warm in places you didn't know could go
or
and then you'll want to be a bad guy
then you'll want to be now
um so right that's that list um
anything anything you thought about that
list before we move on this doesn't
pertain to the list at all just talk
about hard sci-fi for a second have you
all seen because it's one of those
series that is slow and it's not for
everybody but I think we've briefly
talked about it before maybe months ago
or something like that but y'all seen
Foundation right that's just one of
those series that like
not for everybody but it's one of those
ones I can respect a lot because of how
hard conceptual sci-fi it is I guess
yeah just thought about it it's a bit of
a slow burn and you have to you have to
concentrate
yeah
you have to pause it and go away and
never think about it it's it's hardcore
Cipher yeah
um there is a show that I would put on
that list that isn't on there which is
fringe we've spoken about Fringe before
yeah not not the final season but the
first four seasons
they were fantastic and it is probably
one of my favorite sci-fi shows of all
time
it's got one of the best series openers
I've ever seen ever any show any genre
that that opening episode was just
amazing
with that airplane and all the things it
was just incredible
um and yeah it did it did waver at times
but um that entire first season was good
because it didn't feel like the the
later on in the series you've got the
more sci-fi it felt but it felt more
like a
um crime
like
I don't know like a
some things happen we need to figure out
like a crime drama kind of thing yeah
like a procedural drama really in a
mystery mystery yeah that's what got me
hooked initially I watched it and it was
it wasn't the Sci-Fi that the Sci-Fi
kept me but it was I like the the
the crime stuff you know
because this this person's mouth is now
attached to their it's been glued
together and so his eyes What's
Happening Here
I have to figure out I'll have that the
X-Files as well why are these dudes with
their lips and eyes sewn together the
end of season one though when you see uh
what the [__] his name spark in the
Twin Towers
right we gotta get we got a lot to get
through anyway so we'll crack on but um
bit of star star get update that we've
got that I'd love to get your guys
opinion on I I talked about both these
things in the
um weekly video I do on the sides
Channel but like I say want your opinion
and I have a big update on the room
about
um the writers so I got a bit Clarity on
God of War which is which is interesting
but anyway so this Courtney Valenti
there's a Warner Brothers executive
she's now been hired by
um Marvel and Amazon so this is really
is the completion of the merger Marvel
and MGA Amazon and mg I'm sorry now one
company
there's no separation that it's just
depending on which stamp logo they stamp
on the movie at the end
um so she's now been hired as the chief
executive of film cinematic and
streaming for MGM and Amazon now I've
been saying to you guys for ages that
they've really been waiting
for this higher and it's taken a long
time I mean they were they were looking
for this back in August they were
um apparently Amazon are quite famous
for taking forever to hire people
um they have some weird
um strategy on how they do it but anyway
so she's come from Warner Brothers
she basically left not long after Pam
Abdi and Mike DeLuca left
um MGM and went to one of what this was
a bit of musical chairs going on she
reports directly for Jennifer saki
um and that's also that's the only
person she reports to so if the room is
true what we're hearing about this is
going to be a movie first before Series
this really has been what we're waiting
for is this person because they're not
going to announce
any big movie projects why you haven't
got a chief executive film in charge
because what if they're not passionate
about the projects you're going to get
you know so I I honestly think this is
what's been holding this crap up and it
still might be a couple of months yeah
but until we get an announcement because
she's obviously going to be new in the
job but she started in March 1st so
she's in
um what do you guys think about this is
she the one putting that Five-Year Plan
together or do they wait to kind of get
that started for her or apparently the
five year plan has been something
they've been talking about for weeks but
that isn't just
um movies that's movies and television
so that's mainly been a conversation
between Michael Wright and Jennifer
sulky
they're looking at franchises and things
or other things so that but again I
don't think that'll be something that
will be finalized because again I think
they've been waiting for this but also
she's been been interviewed for the last
six weeks to eight weeks at least
so I think she'd have been involved in
those conversations anyway
um so
I don't she won't be coming into this
she's already started the job whatever
the conversations they've had that I
think they'd have been keeping it
should have been involved even if she
understood
it's like a new football manager coming
in and they're looking at transfers they
keep even if they haven't started they
you know they they have a communication
sort of thing
um
but what do you guys think about this is
this something that do you think now the
management team is complete
you know we move on
I mean it's uh I'm I'm excited in in the
sense now everything's complete they can
move on and they can move on to
producing something
what I'm not excited about is if it's
going to be a movie
just because of
the Bad Robot script I know it's not
happening anymore but
what if something just as bad or worse
uh ends up happening what if they end up
doing a couple of elements from that
script and putting it into whatever too
yeah exactly and there's already there's
already an established televisions
television series Without a conclusion
that they could draw from and they could
continue yeah we know Mark Fergus wants
to do that we he's already spoken about
that he wants to do the whole thing with
the planet Builders that's already we've
already got a baked in audience for it
and
it's already something we all want
yeah but Jennifer sulky really wants a
movie and
I don't know I it it it's something that
worries me because I don't
although I'd love a movie
I think a movie would be really cool
having a Stargate movie I don't think
now's the right time I think to a series
first and then have
a movie afterwards like as as kind of
like a a reboot kind of thing I've got a
video coming out on Tuesday
um and this this portion that I'm going
to say is from that but basically
they should basically do the series
continue up wrap up everything from
Target Atlantis Target Universe and then
move into kind of like a reboot but not
a reboot where they bring in new
characters and new stories and things
like that and then from there move into
a movie and stuff like that yeah I think
that's probably the best way to do it
because then it appears as both sides
you've got us as hardcore fans who have
the resolutions to the things we've
wanted resolutions for for the last
decade and then you've got new audiences
who are going to be excited for
something brand new and they get they
get their wish for a movie so yeah and I
honestly think 10 years ago we didn't we
had no chance of getting that type of
show that type of thing where they would
have concluded SGU but now with
streaming services I think they're a lot
braver
to do that because the the attitude
would have been people won't remember no
one will know what we're talking about
but like Star Trek really is proof that
actually yeah they they can and will
Picard season three people are loving it
and there's reference into stuff there's
30 bloody years ago on TNG I think the
social media is a massive massive part
of that because there's so many there's
so many people nowadays like these these
companies can look at the metadata they
can look at like Tick Tock Twitter all
these things referencing these
properties and they can see that there's
people still still wanting to to have
these things conclude like look at this
channel
um every time we make a video about
Stargate how many thousands of views do
we get
report the amount of views I've come
from this channel out of the what two
million or so we've got probably like a
million and a half at least a million
probably Stargate a couple of biggest
videos have always been our Stargate
videos yeah and especially just to
change taxes cracking because I think
that's a really interesting question
what are our top three reasons for being
against Bad robots Star Wars the sequels
Star Trek the new ones and anything else
they've touched in the past decade
we know they were planning and it was
like the most the biggest pile of dog
poo in the world I I actually did a
video and I talked about this and I said
like I'm not that dead set against Bad
Robot I I think they are capable of
doing really good television they're
also capable of doing awful movies on
television I like the Star Trek movies I
do
I just don't think it's Star Trek
they're good films they're entertaining
films they're they're fun generic sci-fi
films
I watched them and I enjoyed them but
this was before I even watched
um the original series and I've said now
I'm on TNG but
yeah I can see it it's not the same
yeah
my issue with it is plain and simple
that I didn't like the plot that that
got leaked to me the the storyline that
was being suggested
um and I thought it was weak to say the
least yeah but um I tried so hard to see
the positives in it but
the negatives outweighed it and I just
think but I think it was naive I think
it was a really I think it was it came
from people that didn't understand the
Stargate fans which is what you could
also argue about the Star Trek movies
that even though they're really good
they're entertaining movies
they were not done for Star Trek fans
and they were done by people that didn't
understand what Star Trek fans wanted
and that's the problem so that's that's
my biggest problem I don't think they
understand what the what we'd want but
they would understand the Stargate
franchise anyway like at all anyway
because their whole thing was bringing
back Raw
which is impossible because he blew up
and then they have the audacity
to kill Jack
but if you think of that from an
outsider don't think of that as a gator
right who who has that passion think
about that from an outside are you going
well we want to do something dramatic to
kick-start a new franchise
killer beloved character and an
executive that doesn't love Stargate
would I can understand that why they
thought that would be a good idea okay
they did that in Star Trek and people
went [__] crazy
if they did that with when when Picard
um the series of Picard came out if the
first episode they killed Picard
you'd be pissed
yeah but I mean the show isn't called
yeah no but it would be it would be a
different show it would be a different
show yeah and they wouldn't have called
it Picard but he's in the first episode
and they killed him a beloved character
you'd be pissed
because you're like oh he's back yes
he's back oh no he's dead
like but it would be dramatic
it would but
and it would get you it would get people
talking and that's what they want they
want an impact it would have an impact
and that's what I'm saying I think from
an outsider from somebody that doesn't
love Stargate they're thinking we want
to create an impact
kill the most beloved character
yeah there's enough majority of your
fans is a good way to kick off a
franchise like it's not saying that I'm
just saying it would be dramatic and it
would have an impact yeah no I agree but
but doing it would would be detrimental
100 yeah
no I I feel like as much as I love the
character Jack and and RDA is the best
that's a Surefire way to put put anybody
that has any emotions towards Stargate
into at least like a a brainstorm of
just okay so where are we gonna go now
that's like the next question you ask
it's it's not a bad idea as much as I
love the character of Jack that would be
legitimately smart from from an
executive standpoint and from Stargate
this from Stargate itself because it's
hard to move past certain things and
Jack O'Neill's a very hard thing to move
past and if we're gonna get on the Next
Generation we have to do something like
that put it this way as well that said
though we've had Ben Browder replace
Jack and it was absolutely fine we
didn't kill Jack we had been brought to
just replace him we've moved on he still
existed and the show was still really
good right you don't have to kill your
most beloved characters shut up Matt
[Laughter]
away let me ask you this this question
then Richard Dean Anderson is an old
fella if he agreed to do a movie I mean
a big cinematic movie but he said I'm
not doing anything else though I'm not
coming back to the series I just but I
but if you put me in a movie I'll do it
and they go right okay then well let's
give you an amazing send-off okay we're
gonna kill you but we're gonna kill you
in a really dramatic way they'll be
amazing and it'll be amazing way to say
goodbye to this character
actors love to die on screen
but I don't want Jack to die
again uh for me you know that's fine as
long as I know he's still alive in the
universe somewhere he's fine what's
worse though is if they bring in
somebody else to play Jack yeah that's
much worse riddle me this riddle me this
apparently because there's the clone of
Jack it could be Jack's clone
but it'll be that's already in Canada
but but then you have because it's an
it's it's the Clone oh I guess the Clone
isn't the uh the animatronic one it's
not like the the cyborg no the the one
who was um created by Loki and it's the
child version of him that grew up about
about the same age as what Jack was in
the original now so would you just be
engaging you'd have to get RDA or
someone that looks like them and de-age
them which cost how much more every
episode yeah
um even in the start of sg1 RDA was in
his 40s
yeah
okay so so riddle me this because I like
what you were saying earlier Matt about
okay do a series and then do a a movie
you could even do a season one of a show
and then the movie and do almost a a
double start up for something and and in
that like series you could finish up SGA
you could finish up SGU and kind of do
it a little more neatly and and not rush
it in a movie you could kind of have
that like almost treated like a mini
series uh for a little bit for that one
little season
put Miles Teller in a movie Big Bang
kill off RDA in that movie that way you
maybe maybe you have them in three
episodes in in that first season that
first little miniseries and then you
have the movie kill him off there you've
had a little bit more of Jack then you
have that emotional impact that okay now
then that's the reason teal Samantha
Carter and Jack uh Daniel Jackson when I
come back is because hey
head honcho's gone we have to pick up
that slack although they've probably
already picked up a lot of that slack
over time there's your movie uh or and
there's your Series start off after the
movie kind of a boom boom pal in a way
and that way they already have all the
Stargate people back in their seats for
this TV show then they have a fan base
already
let's go to the movies I'll tell you
what here's another aftermath the the
the story idea that they put forwards
take out ra and put in Anubis
yeah does that change the whole to me
then all of that very simple change
is brilliant idea because Anubis was the
one grow award that we never actually
defeated the only reason he's gone is
because of Irma desalo
if the Ancients never existed
well no they need to exist for Anubis to
exist but let's imagine they weren't
there
Anubis would have wiped out all life in
a Milky Way and Stargate would have been
done
the only reason he's gone is because
stepping in and he at any point
realistically in the next 10 years 100
years a thousand years a million years
whatever it may be he can return
okay
so that that's established in Canon like
you can't
like you can't bring ra back because
he's dead you can't bring Baal back
because he's dead you can't bring back a
puffies because he's dead but Anubis who
was I would be the scariest girl award
anyway you can bring back and he was he
would make a fantastic movie villain
but as anime antagonist is scary as well
Anubis is just a word that sounds scary
it's like
that sounds crap
necropath um yeah Richard Lee Johnson is
73 but actually he's lost crap loads of
weight he got really overweight a couple
of years ago but he's
he's lost a lot of weight a big rumor
was actually that he was losing weight
because he was going to appear in Brad
Wright's script so he started to sort of
like get ready and obviously that didn't
happen but
hmm right so
um next poll Stargate I like this I can
I will put that okay well let's
start my plan for the episode we'll talk
about season five next week
um
still a secret known to the general
public obviously we know that Brad
Wright's plan was to make the Stargate
known to the public that was going to be
where the episode started I would have
liked to have then had flashbacks when
we did our little mini series where we
talked about what we would do if we were
setting this up we said with our
flashbacks explaining because we want to
know how it became
yeah okay for me I'd rather a skept a
secret
I I think it's more interesting and I
don't want this to become Star Trek I
wanted to stay Stargate and that's
that's really as important to me
yeah
but logically
it's very difficult to still be um
um a secret but what do you guys think
secret or known to the general public I
think keeping it as a secret would be
good because they could tie in things
that have happened over the last 10
years in the real world uh like covid
and they could make out as if it was
something that come through the gate
that could be like pretty cool like
little little nods to things that
happened in the real in the real world
because the the good thing about
Stargate was it always felt like it
could be happening and it was a secret
yeah like I feel like just keep it like
maybe you do disclose it later on down
the line that's fine but you need some
sort of build up I think I don't think
going straight in with oh no oh the star
gets public knowledge now okay but what
happened and your idea with flashbacks
is good but I think there needs to be a
little bit more added like you need to
see it like unfold
rather than like those little oh this
happens so this is why it's now public
knowledge I would just rather it be
the same as it was and then something
happens like some sort of political
um
motive from some new president or
something like that comes in and then
decides that you know we want to make
this public or you know
the Russians have decided to they're
threatening to make make it public and
that's why they've
I don't know that's why there's a war
now with Russia yeah
um
so so the only thing about it being
secret still because I I actually prefer
that I think it would
would still be the best for Stargate
because like Jamie said if you started
off public you're going to have Firefly
or start you're like the Mandalorian you
just have some random person flying
spaceships around it could literally be
anybody uh but if we followed like Eris
Bach like did some cool like Bounty
Hunter stuff I wouldn't be opposed but
uh
uh oh God brain fart always this is this
always happens I try to make a point
um
the best point ever I know I know
but secret would be nice just because
it's it's not gonna I guess the the hard
part with secret is that's that's where
I was uh trailing off to was I guess the
hard part with that is you could
definitely put covet in there and and
talk about okay this is part of this you
could do certain things and add that
but we we could make our current history
part of the show but wouldn't you have
to
because we like you said Russia and like
Russia might be angry so they but they
wouldn't be though right we wouldn't
necessarily do do Russia because I think
that's true yeah yeah I'm just using
that an example because we couldn't do
the exact I guess history of current
time just because we wouldn't be
fighting on our planet like like the one
thing that would be weird is that all of
these governments know like hey well we
can't fight with each other anymore if
you all have this kind of stuff you have
this kind of stuff oh we heard that you
have this kind of stuff We're not gonna
try to fight like in smaller Nations and
stuff like that so in
it would be interesting to kind of hop
in there in like an un on
unprecedented like era of Peace like the
last 15 20 years and then maybe at the
end of like a season one or an end of
season two or something that's when it
kind of becomes known to the public and
all hell breaks loose it's not so
peaceful anymore yada yada uh no way
it's already established in Canon that
the the leaders of the of all the
nations around the world they already
know about the stargate's existence
because there was that that big board
meeting they already know
um
it's just the general public don't know
so maybe you're right maybe there was
like a a period of this last 10 years of
of peace between the Nations at least
um
but things over the course of a decade
things change political leaders change
uh political motives definitely change
like if they know about the Stargate and
they know all these resources that are
out there in the galaxy but perhaps they
want a piece of the pie rather than just
getting you know the U.S so maybe we've
had an unprecedented era of Peace on
this planet and now our own
representative countries are fighting
each other off-site off-world sometimes
even
the series starts that it's a secret so
three nil what what the hell
two goals in three minutes
I'm glad I'm not watching it now Focus
I think this is the perfect way to start
the series to me then it's the secret
and it's it's released I think it would
be so interesting to see how that would
pan out
um before
it might be a bit boring to be fair
because you'd be getting into the detail
of it and stuff but I think it would
just be so interesting
um to see how it would pan out I have
put a poll on the channel though guys if
you want to go and vote
um and at the end of the video remind me
and we'll have a look
um you can you can put it in the chat
for the uh the live chat too a little
pull
we've already had two votes
the thing with uh Keeping a Secret as
well is it adds the stakes for uh humans
as a species become so much higher if
it's a secret
um because they're not only
battling an outside threat but they're
also trying to keep the public safe from
the knowledge because in their mind
they're keeping it safe for a reason
it's not because they're just hoarding
all this information they're trying to
keep the public safe and they don't want
to cause massive stereo and stuff like
that so maybe if something happened
which forced them to release
uh the existence of the Stargate that
would be interesting because you would
see the Fallout you would see the
massive stereo you'd see the riots you'd
see
like little factions of people get
together like oh we don't believe this
you know like anti-vaxxers it would be
like anti-vaxxers but it would be like
anti-antigators kind of thing in the
show
what's the real secret what are they
really doing it would be like uh well
they're trying to control us with this
it it would basically mirror what
happens in the real world but they did
they adapt it to what to the situation
in Stargate and I think that would be
really cool and to be fair I think
probably a better way of doing it in
hindsight is is what we said actually
when we did the we did our little mini
series that we would start
um as
um that it's it's known and you just
don't think and you do flashbacks back
to it and just pick out specific details
of how it got released and I think
because then and water you know and like
boil it down would be more interesting
to watch because something like that
would go on months if that got announced
tomorrow
everything would freak but it would take
months to sort of like
sorry I was doing it like they've done
it with the Last of Us
where the last it's literally you see it
as yeah you see it as as the end of the
world and then you see the stories that
that would be actual I think that would
be the way to do little flashbacks that
explain bits as you go along because you
could do an entire episode on in the
past yeah well you ask questions then as
well or you know in the series you can
you will be like oh why why is that
happening and then they'll explain it
like two or three episodes down the line
in a flashback so it's a good way of
keeping us interested as well isn't it
and but but yeah that's that I I think
that's true so yeah let's we'll see like
I say we've got a couple of votes we'll
give it half hour to to um Bubble and
we'll be on Tick Tock as they're saying
when will there be new seasons coming
out well low beard hopefully we'll get
an announcement within the next few
months but nothing is official yet
nothing is official I've been told that
we should know something by April but I
think that was back last September I was
told that by
um somebody I speak to and I think this
situation might have changed since then
because I don't think movie was a
realistic option then and I think that's
really what like say Jennifer salkey
wants
um
I I think things might have changed so
I I would be surprised if we didn't know
something
by uh this guy's messaging me loads
yesterday no I am not enjoying the game
the game oh it'll be four three don't
worry we'll score four goals in the last
20 minutes
um but no I'm not interested this is a
Sci-Fi channel not a football channel
yeah but I'm sorry
um but but yeah so okay we'll see we'll
go into a little chat now
um another thing I wanted to update so I
got to hold a rumor
um a couple of weeks ago now that
penguin in a park where we're looking at
finding some staff writers they
basically put out the call to some
agents some of the big agencies in
Hollywood saying that you know we're
looking for
um some staff writers to come and work
with penguin and Parker and they did not
disclose what project that was for but
the whisper was
um from
um the guy that I speak to who does work
for one of these agencies he basically
said the whisper is that it's an MGM
project
um so there's two options for that if
that's correct that it's either
um Stargate
or something we don't know about
a little a couple of little updates
wouldn't it be God of War as well
it could be to do with God of War right
so
um development for God of War started
last June now um Hawk ospi and Mark
Fergus are primarily doing writing the
scripts and doing the development work
um at the moment they are pushing for
that now I've been told from one of my
guys um that I'm speaking to is one of
the other reasons why they're not in any
pressure on any rush to announce
anything to do with Stargate even though
they are starting to do preliminary work
is because Mark and Hawk are very busy
on God of War because it's a new series
it's never been done before so a lot of
the early development work is massive
because they've got to figure out how to
take the game and turn into the series
so they've got a big glut of work to do
at the start but then even if it goes
runs on Seven Seasons they've not got
anything like the workload wants that
once they figure out how to do it sort
of thing but that started last June
I've been told the scripts for
um the first sorry first drafts of all
the scripts for the first season had
done and they've been done since before
Christmas
so
um even though they might be bringing on
staff writers to support doing that
the guy I've spoken to two different
sources now and both of them are
reasonably close to this and they've
both sort of said
um Amazon aren't worried about the God
of War situation because Mark Fergus
wants to push with Stargate and Hawk OSP
wants to push we'll we'll basically
um show run God of War
that's always been things but they are
busy
but apparently they're also looking at a
big movie project that one of them has
had
um and they've had an idea for
Apparently one of them wrote a script
this movie ages ago and he's really
pushing to get that made as well
so they really want to expand penguin
and Parker
like JJ Abrams did 15 20 years ago he
expanded that business and he you know
he was writing and doing all the work at
one point he was the main man and now
he's basically a manager penguin and
Parker are trying to do the same thing
so apparently
um pre-production is about to get
started on God of War they're about to
start announcing and at the moment
they're looking at um casting
and my guy says that we should start
hearing casting announcements in the
next month or two
um but actually quite a lot of element
work is done
so um there's been a lot of bouncing
backwards and forwards between Netflix
and penguin and Parker saying that we
want to do this we want to do that
apparently that was done before
Christmas they're happy with like right
that's they they've got um
um all of the idea of where that new
first season is going is done so they're
fine-tune scripts so I don't think
they're taking on people if they're
taking on people for that it's just to
help out with the last bits
um
the thing is that they are the only
people down credited for writing these
so if they're going to bring on staff
writers later it seems a bit strange
they seem to have done most of the work
um
but as I say they they're looking to
expand the penguin in the park at any
way by the same feeling like I say this
movie is something I've not heard before
so again that would maybe you might be
bring people on for that
but again you probably have different
departments for different shows they'll
have different units and that's why
they're expanding exactly and but the
way I was told this guy was just that
actually Mark Fergus more and more is
looking like he actually wants to show
run Stargate
and if he's going to be show running it
he can't write the scripts and do
everything else so there's it looks like
to do all the projects they want to do
they need to bring in writers to support
so it's like it's like Star Trek Picard
tell him Terry metallis did a lot of the
writing but other people wrote episodes
as well
um and that's basically what they would
be doing they'd be like Stargate sg1 you
know Brad Wright didn't write all the
scripts he couldn't was that possible
Robert Cooper didn't there was you know
and seven or eight different writers
doing different episodes and and and
they work on episodes together as well
as a team even though one gets the
credit so that's what it looks like so
um it looks like we're fine
with everything and it looks like the
staff writers of Stargate but we don't
know for sure we just don't that's why
I'm saying it's got to be very much in
the rumor category but it does look like
they're gearing up for something and
it's unlikely that it's just God of War
um if it's not Stargate it's something
else we don't know about
which we'll find out about soon
what do you guys think about that as a
general
thing what does it sound like to you and
this is just opinion now because we
don't notice it
it sounds good it's 4 million ish it
does sound good but
it's just so many unknowns isn't it it's
yeah we it's hard to get excited
when you don't know for sure if it's
that because obviously it's we we know
we know that they're hiring writers
great what for well we don't know and
who are the writers what have their
projects been
etc etc well they're not even at that
point they're literally just at the
point of asking angels
who have you got
who could you send that one they put an
advert out basically anything that's
basically what they're doing they're
putting advert out
I don't know quite how it works in these
circles I'm sure it's slightly different
to like if they were looking for a
cleaner but basically
you know
um competitive wage yeah what we've been
waiting to hear
for like
real things happening you know I mean
like practical things happening this is
the first I think like we've heard about
negotiations
we heard that real thing happening
meetings happening conversations
happening and and I've heard that now
from five or six of different people I
speak to that yeah that was happening
and now we're hearing this I think it's
it's an indication of where we're going
with this but I don't think you can say
more than that it's just okay it's a
good indication it's interesting
but
we can't really and do any more than
that we can't really see anymore
knowing everything that happened
previous
and then essentially getting radio
silence this is
positive it is exciting
but yeah like you said you can't we
can't get too excited because we don't
really know where it's gonna go
it's the first step on a journey of a
Thousand Miles as they say you know yeah
do you know one other thing though I did
here that um you know I said a couple
months ago that there was a big there
was a memo a couple weeks ago the memo
went round anybody that's caught comes
to speak into things and they name drop
Sidetrack
um and another Channel as well
um if you if apparently somebody's
saying because you know it's three
months now since
um we heard about the negotiations
but we haven't had anything since
and um the guy I spoke to says because
they've been a damn site more careful
now
um because there's a security guard
story and they're like if security
guards are telling them and people are
walking and something's up
yeah exactly
um so they seem to be being a little bit
more careful about this so um but we'll
we'll see what happens
hopefully the these things will always
sneak out it'll just don't take a little
bit longer it doesn't matter how careful
they are
it will sneak out someone will leave
something laying around something will
just put a piece of paper down it will
have something on top so someone will
see it and go
that is the evidence I needed and then
well I I can't go into too much detail
because obviously I have to protect
sources but I'm telling you that once it
gets to a point of
stuff getting written down and stuff
getting finalized we will know about it
yeah straight away pretty much because
of the people I know there are the
people in certain positions will know
and stuff as well
once he's in production like in
pre-production and stuff once it's been
finalized as you say they'll be internal
chatter Like official internal chatter
they won't be necessarily an official
announcement externally but internally
they'll know everyone will know
and then like I say and at some point
they'll have to start looking at actors
and all this sort of thing and that will
not so um like I said Dave they've asked
for writers we found out about it
straight away
um honestly that's probably gonna be the
most exciting part of all of it once it
once once it's been green lit on their
side not necessarily that it's official
outside outside of Amazon and MGM but
once they've done it and they're they're
looking for actors and things like that
and we've got little rumors of all this
person might be the lead this person may
be involved that's going to be exciting
because we're gonna have so much more
stuff to talk about and like theorize it
just like looking at their their
previous body of work and then like yeah
these could be good or no no no please
no please no
so yeah I'm excited about all that stuff
yeah I want them to hire one expanse
writer one Lost in Space writer one
Stargate writer that's already ridden a
bunch of things give us a
I don't know I can't think of anything
else give us an X-Files writer give us
and and one other and then we'll be set
I think a crossover
people anyway
hire somebody that actually watched
Stargate there you go we'll start there
yeah and we'll go from there
um that's that's looking positive anyway
because he seems smart focused no
Stargate I was I was amazed there was a
couple of other bits I found out I can't
tell you but there's a couple of other
bits honestly this guy knows Stargate
um that it's it's really exciting
actually there's some of this so I've
heard two or three things now Mark
Fergus saying
um have you seen the the notes that
Shelley put up and um a brain pain needs
to help with chevron's lunchevron's
website I'll check that note out for us
there you go I'll put it up for you
there you go that one
any idea
your block from nine share from login
can you help me out uh I can uh message
me on Facebook
are you in Discord no if you're on
Discord Link's in the description uh
message me on there and I'll help you
out after that
um it's umass.com
um it's not like yeah I might have
changed your link you don't know pnc.gg
forward slash
um
but yeah like I say I think that's
that's really interesting but four
oh Neil
man we're getting [__]
we've been waiting for a really bad
defeat it's been brewing for a while
damn it yeah
if if that Liverpool fan pops back up
because somebody block him for me please
because
thanks really don't don't block him at J
on on every chat
we are pretty much at our hour
fellas so we were going to talk about
season five of sg1 shall we do that in a
week or two when we come back because we
think yeah okay good was there anything
else you wanted to talk about now
well
you'll watch season three episode one of
the Mandalorian yeah yeah
did you enjoy it no it was awful now it
wasn't too it's brilliant
um
I liked it yeah I really liked it I
loved the Kate Sackhoff little yes she
gets hotter and hotter every time I see
him if she's in a show I'm watching it
and it's been that way since I was a
proud
she's going to show and she I don't
follow Star Wars as much as you but they
were
kind of planning on it but I don't think
so anymore because uh because you know
uh Disney Disney cut both Marvel and
Star Wars is or lucasfilms
grand total budget per year and that's
just to keep them from doing too many
projects at once and Star Wars was about
to start doing a lot of projects at once
so they're kind of like we have three or
four right now that are in development
that'll be coming out this year or next
Let's uh let's try to hone in those
shows yeah they're trying to make a more
Game of Thrones like I feel uh put a
bunch of characters into one show
I feel like we'll get more book of Boba
Fett season two and things like that but
I don't think we're gonna get more
spin-off shows per characters like that
uh just because of the way the first one
you know
stupid mic right stupid
Mike right that's that's Brad Wright's
cousin yeah
thank you Mike
yeah fair enough
um
I stopped listening to most of what you
said then because I was just thinking
about how we're losing four now I'm so
sorry
Star Wars shows they're trying to
centralize oh yeah I remember not so
much yeah
um there is a big thing at the moment
that most streaming platforms just
shrink in there
um a budget today
2023 will be the peak this will be where
this will be when the most money gets
spent and every year after this budget's
going to be shrinking and it's HBO
Disney everybody
Netflix everybody I feel like that's a
good thing just because it forces people
to be more creative with their budgets
it it forces people to care about their
projects more instead of ah yeah we'll
toss a couple put VFX guys on it and
post the rings of power this [__]
yeah yeah exactly sure yes of course we
can make good show we spent a billion
dollars on it how would it be bad
well it wasn't bad it's just boring but
um
yeah you and you know that Amazon no
rings of power was boring because every
single story now an article you read now
it goes on about how the change is now
it's going to be different in season two
because I think you know it was crap
they do but I'm I'm glad they're they're
saying that kind of stuff because it's
let me just look at Disney that's what
we're always looking at just the whole
world of fandoms in general just for the
most part is Disney sends this out
Disney sends that out and it's just like
that's a lot that's a lot the fact that
and not all of it's great especially
with Marvel and phase four and in the
way Star Wars has even done a couple
different things as those are just their
head honchos
it's just not as not as pertinent as it
used to be uh hopefully that'll fix it
just a bit you know fingers crossed
um
but uh but yeah serious one Amanda I
thought was it was episode one was great
I think it's setting up a really
interesting storyline again uh I know
it's got to go to the The Living Waters
I'm hoping to eat him
um but those Living Waters have got to
be radioactive that planet was glassed
like there's yeah there's no way you can
get out of that water without looking
like a plutonium dude you're gonna come
out looking like man thing like as you
see a dull glow under the helmetics
um I I put a tweet on the other day just
just I did it in part to annoyed Star
Wars fans I'm so but you know they keep
saying about it it puts the kid's helmet
on you will never take it off will you
no miss yeah promise no I will never
take it off and I'm just like going that
kid's gonna grow that helmet's gonna be
really tight it's gonna be like I
thought that
but the thing is they do take their
helmets off because Mando took it off
the only reason he the the only reason
he's not he's now excited because he
took it off in front of someone they're
allowed to take it off yeah in private
so they need to change the word if no
one in your face
he got a new helmet in the first episode
of the first series for God's saying so
he didn't sort of like I'll take off
this bit you give me a new bit stick
that on there take this thing
yeah
he went around his head like
um and I just want to go I'm actually
shaved
and eat
he has to have everything for a straw
remember season one when he goes and
eats food in the little cabin by himself
and that lady's trying to kind of hit on
him and he's like hey come help and then
the whole village gets impact of course
but you know
it happens anyway so um that is the way
um to never take your helmet off except
for but that wouldn't be as interesting
would it wouldn't be as good a slogan
it's it's like your new channel name
Matt's nerd Corner except it's not nerd
Corner because he hasn't watched Firefly
but when he has watched Firefly he's
allowed to call it nerd corner but until
then it's just the corner so you have to
call yourself in the corner do you know
why I called it do you know why it's the
corner because literally the angle on
that when I film you're in the corner
[__] I'm in a corner
Chase Chris
if I ever do another channel it's going
to be Chase green screen yeah I'm gonna
get another one of these little
sunlights and say I have a double sun
and then I'm gonna just be really star
warsy yeah you know very cool
um
nice song guys I think that's been a
really great chat we say we will come
back and we will do season five in a
week or two
um and there's a there's a couple of
other things that I wanted to talk about
but we'll we'll we'll do it next time
because you know I'm really tired
um every time I roll over at the moment
my back goes
so I go oh so I'm not slept far at all
this last week so every time you see a
score happen and tense up a little bit
you're feeling great yeah yeah well
today
if this has happened a week ago I'd have
been in trouble I'd have been on the
floor
um but yeah at the moment it's not too
bad
at least we're not an Old Trafford loser
there but anyway but now guys thank you
so much for coming
um so a couple of little announcements
um I go down to four days a week now
in my day job thanks mostly to you guys
and the one and me lying to the wife
yeah the channel is making loads of
money but
um
um so um but it does mean that I can do
a few things that I wasn't being I
didn't have time for so we have started
we do now have the patreon
and which is patreon forward slashing
guys if you're a member on the YouTube
channel you do get your little badge and
everything which is great but YouTube do
take like a third of that money and I
don't like giving YouTube money to be
honest because they keep being
unpleasant a really good friend of mine
um has got a YouTube channel he's just
been demonetized For No Good Reason
um and it just wound me up so we got on
patreon I keep most of that money and I
need that money so that the wife lets me
stay at four days a week
um
also we're gonna we now have a um what's
the word a podcast
so the live video from here will be
brought on the podcast and that'll be
sorted Matt's bored and he's filling up
his Vape ready for the next video
um we
um I'm gonna be doing a lot more videos
on the sides Channel
just out me like that just
I could see you
um and everyone else could as well
um so that's it but one of the things
I'm really looking forward to doing is
we're going to be in a lot more articles
on the nine Chevrons website because
I'll have time to actually write them
and Matt's gonna put them on for me
because Daniel will be writing some
himself and better as well you write so
much nicer than I do I need somebody to
start checking my grammar
I do edit your what you send me good
because my grammar is terrible I need to
get my 13 year old son to start checking
my work and send it back home with the
teacher or send it back to school with
his teacher yeah I have a lot of red
under it if it did
I am I am a little bit dyslexic so it
does it does show sometimes I still
don't know what a semicolon is I don't
know what it's for uh or syntax
I don't know what a known or a pronoun
is either
um and why have you got a semicolon
tattooed on your arm
it's it's to continue Google it
there is a reason there's a reason
you've got dirty in it you just send me
to somewhere
um are in the chat though guys um and
all the links are also on the
description
um for the video so please go and have a
look but one of the things I am going to
do a while ago I tried to write a Sci-Fi
I was going to do a Stargate fan fiction
but I just didn't have time so I'm gonna
have another go because now I do have
time because I get one day off a week
um so but I don't think I'm gonna do a
Stargate fanfiction I think I'm just
going to do a Sci-Fi novel but what I
want to do is involve you guys so I will
be writing a bit telling you about it
put it out there somehow I haven't
decided here yet
um and then I will ask you if you're
input and we'll do a little polls
actually this happened actually this
happened and I want it to be a Sidetrack
story so I'm going to involve everybody
and a Sidetrack story yeah and then five
did you the microphone started to like
get goggly for a second like a little
underwater sounding and then he said
five and it cleared up completely
I was like sniffing a little cayenne and
you're just oh okay I'm awake again
should have passed
that would be a fantastic sound bite you
know just you know buttons
do a little Little Mix
I got the little bit to me going oh one
nil two minutes
five five just put it on a little like
sound board and just press it if I was
musically talented I would do that but
I'm not alone
but yeah I think generalization I think
it's all right I think it'll be a lot of
fun to write a Sidetrack novel or story
I don't know you know short story
whatever and um and then we'll put it on
and we'll
see what people think and I will get
somebody to check my grammar and
spelling well I mean the computer does
my spelling
and I'm just generally making sure that
it doesn't sound like a child wrote it
that would be good
um but yeah really looking forward to
that uh generalization is a great name
it's a great name you said and I was
like wait what cut me off guard I love
it
but yeah we're gonna I'm gonna be I'm
gonna look forward to that but like so
yeah I'm gonna really try to put a
little bit more effort and we're going
to try to take the channel to the next
level try and do a bit more a bit more
interaction more lives more stuff like I
say we've got the podcast we got
um we're live right now on Tick Tock
um I believe if it works yeah
um and yeah we're gonna try to go to
that next level and guys if you've got
any ideas on things you want to see I am
in the channel moving forwards let us
know and if we can do it we will
so let's have a look at the poll that we
put on
we had no that's not right I still only
had two votes really
I've only had two votes 100
of those votes let me just see because I
might have lost the internet one second
yeah thank you votes so forget that
um 100 of them say still a secret
it's because everybody that would
normally vote on that is currently
watching us here
um I don't know how to do the live
vote on here but I'll have to I'll
figure it out I don't know if I can do
it through um
that might be the thing yeah I'm not
positive there we'll figure it out next
time
um but guys thank you so much for
attending as always
um no stormy because he is been dumped
on the weekend shift again
um he's trying to get out of it for us
I'm gonna go and punch um Richard
Branson in the face
um so but thanks guys and thank you
everybody in the chat again you've made
it a brilliant chat once again
um some couple of brilliant questions
there that meant that we I might as well
just I got loads of notes throw them
away
irrelevant and but we'll keep up next
week but those thank you so much is
anything you wanted to say before we go
no
not particularly
good quite safe you don't say goodbye to
people or yeah
well we'll see you later okay I love you
guys
especially if it's six
one sec now it's it's nine it's twelve
that's only five now but there's still
eight minutes to go so you know
plenty of something to lose really
really badly then
so you said you want to just watch them
for eight minutes Matt and I will leave
and Jay's just gonna sit here and just
live just react to everything that
happens
if everybody could go inside this track
I'll come and buy a cup that would make
me happy everybody
five anyway enough time to get six then
sixteen two I've lost four games
gotta hate this guy somebody block him
guys thank you so much we will see you
next week
um
what would we do with B movies B movies
hopefully yeah our favorite B movies and
yeah
it's not six nil piss off
that might be our biggest defeat
ever
ever yeah that's the highest score in
soccer or football game I think I've
ever heard of I think our best record is
only like seven one seven nil
is the best we've ever beat anybody
and you know's worst is gonna be the
opposite of that
[Laughter]
okay you guys
I'm so glad I'm live for one of the
worst moments of my entire life
you know this is Gonna Come a clip Joe
yeah
oh dear God in heaven
um apparently now there's more votes on
the thing
nope it's not updating
that would be even better
right and there's still five minutes
left
right okay so I hope Liverpool get
relegated
um anyway guys
we will see you next week thank you so
so much
um have a lovely week guys stay safe
Matt stop playing with your phone you're
live on television mate what are you
doing I'm trying to find the poll
I've been watching the football score
for the last time
thank you so much everybody we'll see
you next week
[Music]